صوتهم عال هنا وراجح
يدافع الاشد تطرفا في اختلاف بنيامين
تنياهو الحكومي عن مقاربات اكثر صداميه مع
الفلسطينيين حلفاء الضروره كما يسميهم
البعض يريدون بصمه في مستوى سمعتهم في
اكثر حكومات دوله الاحتلال يمينيه
بين هؤلاء وزير الماليه
زعيم تحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه
اذ كان عضوا في الكنيست كان يدعو الى
اعاده احتلال القطاع بالكامل وتهجير سكانه
باعتبار ذلك الحل الوحيد مع غزه كما قال
وقال اخيرا من داخل الحكومه انه يتوجب
تغيير معادله الرد تجاه غزه عبر ضربات
موجعه اكثر
يشترك معه حليفه المتطرف الاخر في الحكومه
وزير الامن القومي
في انتقاد ما يعتبرانها ردودا اسرائيليه
ضعيفه ومتراخيه على صواريخ المقاومه قبل
ايام فقط دعا بنجفير الذي يراس حزب قوه
يهوديه المتشدد الى الرد بخمسين صاروخا
على كل صاروخ يطلق من قطاع غزه
تعامل حكومه الاحتلال مع التصعيد الاخير
مع المقاومه على اثر استشهاد قيادي حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي الاسير خضر عدنان
حينها نقلت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه عن
محللين اسرائيليين قولهم ان المواجهات مع
غزه تمهد الساحه لتصعيد كبير بسبب وجود
مسؤولين متطرفين على راس مؤسسات امنيه
اسرائيليه
قبل التحاقه باعتلاف نتنياهو وبعده ظل بن
جبير يطالب بما يدعوه دحرجه الرؤوس في
القطاع وحتى يحقق مبتغاه تجده حريصا على
ان يلعب في حكومه نتنياهو دورا رئيسيا في
اتخاذ القرارات الامنيه وخصوصا المتعلقه
منها بغزه تلك واحده بمسائل فجرت ازمه بين
شريكي الائتلاف الياباني المتطرف سرعان ما
بددتها الغارات الاسرائيليه على القطاع
والتي استشهد فيها قاده من سرايا القدس
وعائلاتهم يقول اطمار بنج فير ان العمليه
بدايه جيده وانه ان الاوان لتغيير السياسه
تجاه غزه